attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
et alors c'est si la fiesta
tiens je t'aime nez du vin de merde j'ai
acheté la supérette on va j'ai essayé de
gratter ticket de sa marche pas fait
gaffe à ce que mon ami piqueté ce tueur
bon allez c'est l'étiquette enfin parce
que là comme ça en soient exclues s'il
faut faut le boire que si on est très
très beau et bien j'ai merdé personnes
j'ai fait exprès comme vous êtes
toujours en retard du coup je vous ai
dit de venir une demi-heure avant les
autres mais on fait exprès d'arriver en
retard pour pas être les premiers voilà
on s'est fait avoir encore être obligés
d'ouvrir caouette
mais du coup ça ça j'aime bourrer la
gueule je vais [ __ ] la honte non tulle
empêche de voir un peu quand même mais
je trouve tout le monde sait ça m'excite
j'adore d'ailleurs attachement ferme à
clé moi j'ai changé les bras ce matin
sinon je peux pas aller chez habitat
guetta when sur la numéro six matches
avant toi tu va péter un truc ça va
c'est moi vous êtes qui vous d'ailleurs
non mais s'il ya une demande et au
rayonnement du coup les rangs mais l'air
de direct bon bah
partir très vite sauf à mademoiselle des
gros seins elle en fait ça fait deux
trois verts n'est pas farouchement
alors on va commencer par le premier
c'est pas vous savvis à lui qu'est ce tu
fous ça fait 3 heures on t'attend bon en
fait jamais de soirée ce soir donc bien
on fait autre et puis en suisse pas top
vous ici en disant que ça pouvait pas
être pire qu'en fait votre choix
je regarde déjà tient cadeau
indispensable quand on domine un score
assez gentil ça sent le cadeau de merde
ah ouais c'est un tout peu à 14 euros
donc évidemment on saigne à 5
vous savez pas trop cher pas personne
voilà lé copains j'ai ramené un cd de
bourges coiffeur d'énergie guide c'est
pas bientôt un peu phillies bordel on
nous empêche de dents bien c'est ça non
pas du tout c'est leur passé tout ça
mais non c'est juste que j'ai pas d'amis
je suis tout seul chez moi et ça me fait
chier d'entendre les autres s'amuser
alors que moi j'ai pas de soi et alors
vous payez que sont maintenant qu'ils
ont bravé ces leçons reçues il n'y a pas
de souci déclare la porte on baisse le
son et on va attendre trois minutes et
on va remettre le son à fond vous
appelez pas la police un cabanon
je vais pousser de l'abus sur mon balcon
je peux pas je suis bloqué non tout
allez bonne soirée de merde c'est écrit
[Musique]